[Music]
earlier this month GameSpot had the
opportunity to sit down and play around
8 hours of anthem we started at the very
beginning played through the first story
missions messed around in free play and
wrapped the session with a high-level
stronghold mission Vinc strikes from
destiny while there's still a lot we
don't know about anthem we did have the
chance to chat with lead producer Ben
Irving to talk about anthems progression
loot and difficulty he even hinted at
what to expect from the end game yeah so
the core of the game is your pilot you
know the pilot enters the javelin and so
the pilot is a thing that has the levels
in it and so as you play the game you
level from 1 through 230 is kind of the
main that gets you through the bulk of
the crit path and then you'll do some
other activities to kind of get to level
30 so on that journey you get loot so
you play missions and loot drops and you
pick it up and when you go back to for
Tarsus you go to the forge and you can
discover what that loot was and you can
equip it the loot that drops is based
off your pilot level so as you get
higher in pilot level you'll get a
higher loot and so in the game right now
it's called gear score so if you're a
pilot level 5 then you get like level 5
gear so that's kind of the basics of the
loot system then beyond that there's
rarities so much like many RPG games we
have a color system that goes from
uncommon to legendary for us that goes
for you know white green blue purple
orange yellow I think is our progression
and then as you're playing the game it's
like well how do I get higher rarity
gear and so by doing by setting a
difficulty to a higher level increases
your chance of getting more regular and
then doing harder content increases your
chance so for example if you play a
stronghold on hard you have a much
higher chance of getting rare loot
than if you were to go out and free play
on easy that's like both the easier
content and the easy difficulty then you
would have a lower chance now you can
get loot anywhere but if you'll if you
Laurel out there to be like I want to
become the most powerful person in the
world you'll find that efficiency mark
of like difficulty and challenging
content and you want to do harder stuff
to get those better
rewards because drops are dictated by
pilot level and not gear score this
means that if you decide to swap
javelins it won't take long for you to
trick it out with decent gear once you
hit pilot level 30 you unlock three new
difficulty levels this is when things
get a bit harder and you'll start
getting some very rare loot so at level
30 the three new difficulty is open
that's Grand Master one two and three
and that again will increase the the
loot drop chance so you know it kind of
goes like I said uncommon common rare
epic master work legendary so you get to
a point where you really want those
master works and Legendary's that's
where like the fun properties come in
that change how you play the change of
builds that that like you know a weak
point strike you get it'll reload you
get a free charge you know things like
that that totally change how you play
kind of create builds and rotations and
stuff like that so when you really want
lots of them that's when you'll start
pushing Grand Master one two and three
and you'll need to have you know at
least a set of epics probably some
master works to go in there again
depending on skill level and a bunch of
things but but for those kind of high
end players we want this almost infinite
chase right that you can keep pushing
harder difficulties for kind of bragging
rights amongst your friends to try and
get that better gear and then over time
we'll see how that goes and we might add
more difficulties beyond that it sounds
like difficulty will be a significant
part of anthems endgame but Irving also
shed some light on legendary contracts
and how they plan to expand anthem and
its end game in the future the things
you do at endgame will be legendary
contracts and the strongholds and a 10 a
10 game they'll be tougher we do believe
in aspirational content I think in other
games you can call that raids so we we
do have plans for aspirational content
alive service we're not talking about
that or what the details are yet but we
do recognize the idea that hey like you
want to do something a couple of times a
week with a group of friends that is
hard that really pushes yourself and
then the rest of the time you'll do all
the other parts of the game to kind of
get yourself ready for the next time you
go into the aspirational content and so
I think there are just horizons there
like at the start of the game your
horizon is level
2:30 complete the [ __ ] path understand
the game unlock all the javelins workout
what builds you like the next horizon is
like the legendary contracts and
strongholds and trying to get a full set
of master works and getting the builds
that have the special properties to them
and then the horizon after that will be
aspirational content there's a little
bit of time in there and we just want to
kind of pace it out so that players who
kind of migrate through that you know
progression horizons anthem officially
launches on February 22nd on PC Xbox one
and ps4 a VIP demo will be available on
the 25th for those who pre-ordered it
and an open demo will follow the week
after we have a lot more anthem coverage
planned so stay tuned the game spot
[Music]